du 23 au 26 mai 2010 neuf des citoyens
de toute l'europe bien sûr élisent leurs
représentants au parlement européen pour
cinq ans ses représentants ou par vos
bâtiments sur les textes des lois
appliquées pour par les états et l'union
européenne alors on entend toujours à
chaque fois qu'il faut prendre un wind
décision on entend toujours le
gouvernement de dire non mais non peut
passer l'europe donc pour vous dire que
ces sélections mine de rien vont être
importantes
alors les thèmes qui intéressent le plus
les français à 35% la lutte contre le
terrorisme 36% l'environnement et le
développement durable
36% également les impôts la fiscalité
39% le pouvoir d'achat est en première
position comme je voulais dit à 41%
c'est l'immigration qui arrive en tête
alors autour de la table les
éditorialistes doit-on réduire
l'immigration il y en a deux qui disent
oui je pense que c'est un petit oui pour
eric naulleau un plus grand oui oh oui
ah oui pour andré bercoff ribérac où la
macif mais oui absolument oui pourquoi
pour une raison extrêmement simple c'est
que d'abord il faudrait quand même un
tout petit peu d'histoire mais rapide
je rappelle il faudrait fournir aux
années 90 c'est très intéressant de voir
ce qu écrivait lui la moue paix à
l'époque crpr plus sud est y à l'époque
années 90 où al si vous lisez ce qu'ils
écrivaient bien mais de façon officielle
marine le pen serait une dangereuse
gauchiste à côté il fallait supprimer
immigration clandestine renvoyer tout le
monde
la france n'est pas une vivre ensemble
truc de civilisation sérions il faut pas
c'est pas creuset culturel de plusieurs
civilisations et c est dans le même
temps et dans le même temps
à gauche le secrétaire général du parti
communiste
un certain georges marchais disait ça
suffit les migrations
ça suffit les obligations d'investis il
faut enlever un certain nombre de choses
il faut arrêter parce que ces gens là
sont venus pour casser les salaires des
français vous avez à droite comme à
gauche
vous aviez un consensus en tout cas qui
étaient là et comme par hasard comme par
hasard 25 ans après ça se déchire mais
plus du tout avec mm
mais il faut se rappeler ça il faut
rappeler ce que c'était que le le
paysage sylla ont compensé
c'est bien d'avoir rappelé qu' ce qui se
passe avant vous vous dites lui pour
quelles raisons moi je dis bruit pour
une raison extrêmement simple
je vais citer un journaliste qui connaît
beaucoup mieux l'afrique que je crois à
tous les gens ici réunis qui s'appelle
stephen smith
il dit c'est très simple d'ici 2050 il
ya 50 millions d'africains qui veulent
venir en france
et attention je les comprends je veux
dire en france alors en europe
au contraire le problème si vous voulez
c'est que vous avez aujourd'hui avec les
décalages avec les inégalités vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui rêvent de venir en
europe à londres etc etc
c'est normal ce sont des terres
d'immigration comment on fait quand je
dis je suis contre quel est le cursus ou
mais le long mais là les curseurs mais
voilà on met le curseur à quel niveau et
c'est parce que c'est très bien de dire
ça mais moi j'étais extrêmement frappé
deux choses d'abord une partie du show
biz qui dit accueillons accueillant
accueillons j'en ai pas vu un qui
accueillit dans sa résidence secondaire
c'est quand même intéressant mais ça
c'est normal oui je sais je l'aï ce ppv
démagogie mais bon c'est andré bercoff
alors allez-y refus du maire confirme et
deuxièmement ne s'était pas du merkel
sait des choses très très précise c'est
à dire faites à pognon accueillons mais
attention pas chez moi à côté chez moi
pas proximité de chez moi c'est trop
facile et enfin et enfin je simplement
je venais dire ça c'est que on ne fait
pas des migrations de masse sans savoir
comment on va les accueillir
de quelle façon et qui va avoir qui va
payer au bout sens dans tous les sens du
terme voilà c'est pour ça que je dis
c'est trop facile de dire oui oui et de
faire de l'humanisme sur le ferait déjà
on va avoir la vie de nos invités dans
un instant avec de l'eau non je n'ai pas
d'amis des raisons très différentes moi
je pense qu'on peut pas parler
sérieusement de l'immigration choisie
si on lutte pas contre l'immigration
subie c'est-à-dire cheveux des contrôles
aux frontières de l'europe et aux
frontières de la france et je veux
surtout c'est peut être dur à entendre
mais que les gens qui sont déboutés du
droit d'asile
l'ipch le territoire français sinon il
n'y a plus de règle voilà donc
l'immigration clandestine je suis pour
la sévérité maximale
ce que je voudrais répondre à andré
bercoff sait si on veut plus du tout
d'immigration ça peut être un choix mais
ça veut dire qu'on renonce à toutes nos
valeurs
l'immigration principal l'immigration
légale c'est le regroupement familial
l'europe en famille à lille est
justifiée par le fait qu'on estime que
quelqu'un quelqu'un a droit de vivre à
l'étranger dans un environnement stable
dans un environnement
harmonieux et ça ne peut pas être stable
et harmonieuse et votre famille est à
2500 km donc il faut renoncer
il faut renoncer à ça il faut renoncer à
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme il faut renoncer au droit
d'asile qui est un droit fondamental et
voyance est le pays des droits de
l'homme nous accordons l'asile à ceux
qui se sentent menacés dans leur pays il
faudrait renoncer à un vecteur de
rayonnement crucial même primordial de
la france c'est à dire qu'un accueil des
étudiants étrangers moi je suis pour
l'accueil autant que possible des
étudiants étrangers y contribuer au
rayonnement de la nano au lieu de 0,1
des records c'est la submersion il ya 50
millions d'africains il faut dire c'est
possible d'arrêter toute l'immigration
il faut renoncer avec la france ait
renoncé à être français
voilà alors karim zéribi jugeant non je
dis non parce que d'abord je dis non
parce qu'il faut répondre à la question
mais je trouve qu'elle est pas tout à
fait bien posée faut-il gérer nos flux
migratoires la réponse est à l'évidence
oui tout pays gèrent ces flux
migratoires
toute nation j'ai reçue du meeddat war
même les pays du sud par les pays du
maghreb il y aller fut médiateur avec
l'afrique subsaharienne
de ce côté là il n'y a pas de je dirais
de de crime a à gérer ce flux
migratoires après c'est comment on
traite à question de l'immigration est
là prête toujours de manière hystérique
dans notre pays c'est quand on dit
immigration islam musulmans ça monte
dans le d'aller dans l'est dans les
tours on devient fou on est dans une
forme de passion irrationnelle et on
n'arrive plus à poser le débat avec
lucidité responsabilité l'immigration
depuis 15 ans c'est environ entre 200 et
250 mille personnes qui rentrent avec un
titre de séjour sur notre sol et aux
sarabandes 0,34 pour cent de la
population nationale 0,34 pour cent de
la population et des besoins tester rik
hemeryck et gilles aussi faire ça
n'empêche pas le débat évidemment il
faut le débat moi je veux dire une chose
l'immigration on en parle toujours comme
quelque chose qui coûte j'aimerais qu'on
en parle dans sa globalité
il ya une étude qui a été faite une
dizaine d'années qui disait que
l'immigration coûté 68 milliards à la
remporter ça alors elle a rapporté 72
on avait un gain de 4 milliards pourquoi
parce que dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens dans la manière dont on
traite les bas l'immigré c'est celui qui
viennent profiter de quelques chaussures
c'est celui qui ont profité des aides
sociales sacré
je suis désolé de vous le dire n'en
déplaise à ceux qui sont contre
l'immigration ballack avec une forme de
sa vie
les intégrations c'est aussi des
commerçants bien sûr des artisans des
chefs d'entreprise ces six cent mille
29% des maîtres de seine en région paca
ile de france et occitanie si vous ne
voulez plus d'immigration
on aurait 30 % de médecins moins dans
ces territoires
l'immigration c'est aussi une valeur
ajoutée pour le pays alors moi
effectivement je pense qu'on doit avoir
une politique qui s'appuie sur ses deux
jambes
ouverture avec une gestion des flux
migratoires mesure est régulée sur la
base de critères clairs et quand on
rentre pas dans les critères on n'a pas
à obtenir un titre de séjour dans le
pays et quand on est dégoûtés on doit
être reconduit dans son pays
de ce côté là je n'ai aucune ambiguïté
et puis fermeté fermeté parce que on a
aussi parfois des politiques qui
demandent peu nu sont un petit peu
faible dans le respect des règles de
notre pays
moi je considère que on doit être moins
laxiste qu'on ne les deux que sur
certains aspects je donne un exemple on
avait 1 % des détenus aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont étrangers pourquoi on a pas de
compétition avec les pays d'origine pour
que les peines s'effectue dans le pays
d'origine
peut-être que cette rigueur cette
fermeté l'a7
je dirai comment dirais-je cette
autorité là on en manque un petit peu
donc il faut savoir dire que
l'immigration ça rapporte au pays et je
les dis je les dis les cotisations
sociales les impôts les immigrés payent
des impôts payent des cotisations
sociales
donc il ya des retraites aujourd'hui qui
sont assurées aussi parce qu'on a des
immigrés qui cotisent de les immigrés ce
n'est pas un fardeau pour la société
et puis aujourd'hui on la voix d'un
certain côté l'immigration ne soyons pas
dans ce non pas d'angélisme en la loi
africaine on la voit maghribi donc ça
veut dire derrière la religion mashaie
mais l'immigration l'a toujours eue elle
a toujours vécu des moments difficiles
moi j'ai grandi avec des italiens dans
mon quartier d'enfance on les traitait
de tout ça le [ __ ] il y avait des
ratonnades contre eux ils étaient trop
croyable
donc on a eu le portugais je m'excuse
les italiens n'ont jamais jamais c'est
du fantasme
le brillant je connais le merlan
quartier sicilien du merlan un tu
connais très bien ce quartier numéro lui
lui dans le quartier sicilien du merlan
n'y avait pas de problème de ratonnades
et nîmes est arrêté et même au 5 avenue
arrive ni même faire connaître quelqu'un
il le connaît aucun l'italien et eric
gil de ratonnades de fondamental au 19e
siècle
villarreal 10e syrie je te regarde pas
entendre dire n'importe quoi
merci c'est l'échelle finir merci à les
voir un peu les niveaux d'histoire aller
sur internet parce que la ville la
réalité c'est que encore une fois quand
on prend les études sérieuses et les
chiffres je roule je retrouve le chiffre
et je le redis de cette étude qui a été
faite l'immigration coûte 68 milliards à
la rapporte 70 arrêtez de faire passer
je ne mets car il les avale nice et 10,7
milliards de coûts nets selon des études
sérieuses de l'ifra qui évitera de
l'ifrap ni sérieuse mais je sais quoi
avec sud de gens qui sont très sérieux
avec des intellectuels comme je sais que
vous allez palais mais bien sûr ces
chiffres ont été repris 17 milliards de
coûts n'est pas l' ocde deuxième chose
et ligny ramasser un l'immigration les
voilà servis moral et me donner ses fils
après l'émigration n'est pas un problème
en soi
le problème c'est l'immigration de masse
et l'immigration non choisi et je
rejoins le top league rassurés sur ce
qui a été dit de l'immigration non
contrôlée n'est pas une bonne
immigration et aussi parce que finir je
vous laisserai par les définir
l'intégration ne marche plus le vrai
problème c'est même temps l'immigration
c'est quand on ne peut plus intégrées
parce que soit il ya aussi une part de
responsabilité française on n'a plus la
pêche pour intégrer à à l'époque de mes
parents qui étaient émigrés des italiens
immigrants tunisie on arrivait à faire
des français à distance c'est formidable
on fabriquait des français à tunis à
distance au liban j'ai rencontré des
gens qui étaient français au liban sans
ces scandaleuses que vous dis non c'est
allier étaient des immigrés c'est
n'importe quel salarié c'est de finir
les sicile et en tunisie était pauvre
c'était des immigrés qui faisait des
petits boulots c'était pas du tout des
colons c'est scandaleux
les contes les états unis moi j'aimerais
j'aimerais lui reviennent je veux dire
qu'avant savait intégrer le problème
c'est qu'on ne sait plus on en attendait
le problème fondamental français pour
vivre en commune
il faut des valeurs communes et on n'est
plus capable on n'est plus capable
d'imposer nos valeurs à ceux qui
viennent c'est le ça le problème est
mental on ne sait plus intégrée et on a
le droit
pour les affaires et la reine n'avait
fait que vous ne serez pas quand on
essaie immigration alors je compatis
mais c'est pareil c'est assez difficile
sur vous ces bons produits mais oui je
sais que parmi les immigrés aussi en
plus on est presque tous comme des
migrants
je suis déterminé à les hestayres bon
écoutez si on faisait le tour de ses de
ce plateau et on lisait la biographie de
chacun on verrait que nous sommes que
nous portons certains d'entre nous des
noms étrangers
là je sais je dois non tunisiens
alors si on veut et on verrait déjà que
nous sommes tous ceux qui ont cette
biographie nous sommes intégrés
nous ne sommes pas au rsa nous avons
fait des études
nous nous sommes à des postes honorable
voyez à part moi à part vous mais oui
vous êtes trop modeste il faut faire
mépriser les wallons cloutés et
allait-on ces fentes alpha méprisés
c'est la première fois que la victime
soit lésé allez-y vos fantasmes je vais
vous donner les vrais chiffres de
logements c'est pas moi qui les ai pris
alors aujourd'hui en france la peau la
proportion d'étrangers et de 4,6 pouces
c'est faux
depuis cinq ans
des fois je veux qu'on s'enrichit
festayres des houches les sushis lequel
driessen shiloh les cellules 3% en
allemagne
je vais en été mais chief là vous voilà
c'est cette émigration à 20 millions de
français d'origine étrangère qui vous
plaît laissez la fille ces crapules qui
sont français mais ça me sens pas que le
gris respecte pas d'immigration ici mais
laissez nous parlait les hestayres ça
suffit quoi voilà en écoute sur terre en
fête et la saison cependant alors on
défonce 2017 2018 il y avait 2 155 5000
personnes qui ont tu leurs papiers
d'accord vingt-cinq mille demandes
d'asile économique revin dit bill et tu
es monté non non classés marine et
vanilla
l'accouchement familiale 32000
économique et 90 1082 mines étudiants
alors il n'y a pas de quoi
n'est ce pas être submergé par c'est
l'équivalent dans la ville de toulouse
qui arrivent chaque année
et bien non sérieux
de personnalisation et le problème c'est
l'accueil monza nous ne savons pas
accueilli y en a qui veulent pas aller
jusqu'à un peu quand même mais c'est pas
possible pour faire des contre vérités
antagonistes et les élèves désormais
c'est au machisme annoncé la chaîne
toujours pas au bas des immeubles
il ne serait pas comme à la porte
d'aubervilliers où j'ai été lundi il ya
des familles qui ont des papiers
messieurs alors ils ont des récépissés
oui des titres de séjour ils sont dans
des igloos avec des enfants on vient
s'empaler combien il a bien écouté la
majorité avait des tabacs enfin tant du
côté du bien ça vous agissez vite
fausses en grèce on va les centres de
détention est bouffé temps de rétention
fait les camper marc hé oui je ne
raconte pas des bêtises et vous fait pas
au sérieux et waterloo oak racing joue
fair play c'est hélas la même masse à on
se calme en nageant messia avec nous et
délégué national aux études au sein du
rassemblement national
vous vous dites il faut interdire tout
simplement l'immigration vous êtes né au
caire vous au nom de hossam et vous avez
changé votre prénom pour jour oui
pourquoi 1904 parce que ça ça fait
l'assimilation française d'accord voilà
les vrais films en france on vous je me
suis je suis je suis ont comme on dit un
français de souche par naturalisation
d'accord dont des recrues au sein de
services à vous plaisait pas non en fait
le buzz et bojan c'est montcourt gens
c'est mon prénom de ma peine je reprenne
mon arrêt nom de baptême d'accord pour
répondre à cette question parce que
c'est quand même le but de l'émission
c'est pas de parler de moi les migrants
l'immigration ballon
je faillis je suis effectivement le
fruit de ce qu'on veut de l'immigration
qui se faisait il ya 30 ou 40 ans au
moment au moment où l'immigration
étaient peu nombreuses et au moment où
il existait quelque chose qui s'appelle
le creuset républicain ou tout
simplement la france était la france
donc une peu une faible immigration avec
de forts vecteurs assimilationniste
culturelles économiques aussi bien sûr
parce que l'économie d'il ya 40 ans ce
n'est pas l'économie d'aujourd'hui
autrefois on avait toutes les conditions
avec peu d'immigrés aujourd'hui on a
quasiment aucune condition avec beaucoup
d'immigrés donc ça peut pas fonctionner
l'immigration il faut juste en parler de
manière dépassionnée
l'immigration est ce que c'est une
chance pour la france bat en famille
c'est le bonus si l'immigration louis
l'immigration est une chance
attendez mais laissez moi finir et c'est
le flux d'immigration c'est
l'immigration est une chance pour la
france c'est l' amalgame le plus c'est
l'amalgamme le plus crétin c'est le
blâme algam le plus crétin qu'on puisse
sortir en réalité ça dépend quand et ça
dépend qui l'immigration n'avait pas
tout le temps une chance pour la france
cela on privant les allées comme dans
les années 50 et 60
l'immigration de travail avec l'aveu par
creuser les bruits aux était une chance
pour l'art en suisse
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus une chance
pour la france je suis pas sûr que nous
avons nous avons sur le taux de chômage
des étrangers est beaucoup plus
important quatre fois plus important que
le taux de chômage national
nous avons quatre cent mille étrangers
au rugueux qui sont au chômage
donc il faut qu'on arrête on a six
millions et demi de chômeurs et 9000 aux
pauvres donc beaucoup d'immigrés
monsieur vont commencer
alors même que ceux qui sont déjà sur
notre territoire ne sont intégrés ni
conomique mans ni culturellement
je dirais je termine juste une phrase je
dirais que la situation à laquelle on
arrive aujourd'hui c'est le résultat de
ces quarante années de terre brûlée
identitaire que les gouvernements
successifs ont infligé à la france je
vois aujourd'hui les immigrés sont
assassinées là quoi quand on a un
président de la république qui dit la
culture française n'existe pas les
[Musique]
assimiler à rien n est fait de la france
un désert identitaire donc été lésé les
épreuves les émigrés les immigrés peu
plus sa signification de l'isaf s'est
lancé dans l'arsenal du creuset français
de cause et républicains ça provoque la
mort eric naulleau ou la même chose en
arrêtant dirais que nous faudrait une
précision une question une précision la
question c'est est ce que vous proposez
l'arrêt de toutes les immigrations que
j'ai tout à l'heure c'est un objectif
bien sûr qu'on pourra jamais y arriver
les grilles dégâts à tort attendez
attendez avec remontée entre eux entre
450 et un délit mais pas tous ont posé
question répondre aux mutations qui est
bonne immigration
on va se calmer il ya une immigration
immigration qui est bénigne gageons
qu'ils pardonnent
évidemment on se calme non non non la
psychiatrisation de la nouvelle
politique
ça c'est votre celi vous dites vous dis
ouais harry les bons comptes faisant
rien donc vous parler chacun notre tour
d'argent et réclusion je vous demande si
je vous repose la question est ce que
vous êtes contre toutes ces immigrés que
j'ai énuméré toutes l'euro mais ça ne
vous l'a dit quelques sauf quelques
besoins extrêmement rare dans des
métiers extrêmement rare droits de
l'homme l'objectif va bientôt laisser
passer ça l'immigration ça abandonné le
droit d'asile c'est le co2 c'est un
autre alors je sais je suis bien
d'accord que c'était totalement dévoyé
et c'est devenu un canal des migrations
merci de le préciser mais ce que je veux
dire que vous êtes contre toute forme
d'immigration ça me fait sourire pas
entre quatre et huit mille immigrés et 0
à hawija même que la main de maître eric
naulleau n'a sa part bien votre
explication mais vous dites il faut
dépassionner et tout et vous commencez
avec news et des foules énormes et les
activités manuelles macro il n'a pas dit
y'a pas de culture n'existe pas
la phrase on y est il faut la cité
entièrement là ce que vous faites c'est
de la désinformation et bien
malheureusement côtes dès qu'on commence
à discuter d'immigration la
désinformation comédiens sur bellerose
et vous en êtes ni lu les livres je
donne une fausse logiciel
immigrationniste et vous essayez tordre
la réalité ça corresponde à l'argent
je me grey c'est les musulmans non non
mais non alors été la charge avait dit
quelque chose jamais fia j'avais dit il
avait dit que l'islam était incompatible
avec la république
bien sûr et 10 ha bah bien sûr vous
pouvez développer les [ __ ] développer
la rue moi je parle de religion je parle
pas d'individus la religion islamique
vous savez ce que c'est vous savez ce
que c'est le coran quand le colle au
corps entier s'activent il gère le coran
c'est un code civil c'est un côte c'est
un code pénal c'est un code familial etc
c'est un mode d'organisation clips
politiques et pagnes et social ces
lobbys hors jeu peut pas on peut pas
avoir en face de moi des gens qui se
drapent des oripeaux des valeurs de la
république le fait qu'ils considèrent
que la lapidation des femmes en cas
d'annoncé passé je dis attention je
parle de religion je ne confonds pas
avec les musulmans
je passe du temps à les lire le coran
elle est infondée le joaillier qui vous
confondez le voile et le serre tête
allait d'abord nirlo est ensuite allé
lire depuis tout à l'heure aux tourner
autour du pot les gens savent aurélie
régler ça veut dire par exemple être
musulman ça c'est dire qu'on ne peut pas
s'intégrer vous a beaucoup entendu le
creuset républicain le cas vous
tournerez télé c'était les choses de
retour et ça voulait dire c'est que si
on s'applique pas jambes si on n'est pas
chrétien si on n'a pas la même saveur la
bonne religion se battre j'ai plein
essor vous moi je vais vous dire vrai 10
arrivée parle à ma place bon sens je ne
sais pas d'où ça vient malgré vous j'ai
pas dit ça on va le faire
l'intégration s'est passé votre délire
ça mon poste
[Musique]
numéro de l'intégration mais ce monsieur
sait qu'en france on est le pays qui
donne le moins de cours de français aux
gens qui arrivent en france parce que
les gens comme vous son compte
le sujet de l'intégration c'est qu'on
propose pas aux gens de savoir quels
sont les diplômes qu'ils avaient dans
leur pays de savoir qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent pouvoir qu'est ce qui peut faire
quand il arrive en france
moi je vous parle d'un monsieur que j'ai
rencontré tout simplement chez moi à
cergy pontoise vous savez j'ai fait un
rapport sur l'intégration je sais que
vous avez vous avez déjà répondu sur ce
rapport que j'ai remis au gouvernement
un exemple simple ce monsieur il est
arrivé infirmiers de série il a une deux
ans pour avoir les cours de français
nécessaire pour reprendre ses études et
trois ans pour repasser son épouse et
pourtant c'est ça le problème aux
opérations avant de passer un diplôme de
la maximalisation hongrie et ce monsieur
hees avait réclamé 50 pour pouvoir
reprendre passer son diplôme à franchir
dont j'aimerais vraiment entre bernard
laporte
d'abord ce que ce qui est gênant
effectivement dans ce genre de débats
passionnés c'est que tout le monde
annonce des chiffres aussi réellement
jamais quels sont les acteurs et ça
c'est vraiment super dit le comte tu
mènes le dessinateur il mais qui dit la
vérité ou qui manquent aussi c'est que
il ya une certaine à certains parents
sûr que ça m'agace ça m'agace
profondément voilà non moi je sais pas
s'il faut réduire
s'il faut augmenter ou s'il faut garder
le même nombre
ce qui est sûr c'est que il faut réguler
on a besoin de l'immigration si aussi
simple que ça en a besoin je lis j'ai
tout à l'heure trois cent cinquante
mille emplois qui vont être non pourvus
dans la restauration dans le bâtiment
ont fait et stratégies et en même temps
des routes à leur venue au monde qui
disaient ils avaient des italiens vous
gériez avec des marocains avec avec des
polonais etc
mais oui il a raison ça c'est l'histoire
ça c'est l'histoire
on est tous pour une immigration
contrôlée régulier ça c'est clair et
c'est vrai que malheureusement ce que
l'on mois à l'apporteur chapelle ce que
l'on voit à la jeune et c'est ça donne
pas une bonne image
il faut la régler la red bien mais on a
besoin d'eux les meilleures chances et
je crois qu'elles courent une fois un
grand pays c'est un prix qui s'est
impliqué et qui doit accueillir
on a avec le président du parti la
dissidence française le grand
remplacement
vous dites est une réalité je milite
pour la remise gracieuse leur âme seul
nom expliquez-nous pour vous vous êtes
vous êtes donc bien sur l'immigration
oui il est là réduire avec la région où
la selas l'agent vous paraissait
sympathique j'en garde je n'espérais pas
fouillé sur les ouvrages de design du
bien aux migrations là forcément on est
encore sur un autre level donc je ne
peux pas parler gentiment prié de partir
de le faire en fait c'est ça la s'envola
tu me dis pas la faire oui mais vous
calmer dans vos classes donc
concrètement déjà faut admettre ou une
réalité
contrairement aux chiffres avancés qui
sont les chiffres faut pas s'en faire
eurostar nous aider c'est factuel je
donnais deux chiffres vous avez chiffres
du mieux ça l'intérieur d'accord pour
aller 70 150 mosquées en france
d'accord 2015 2400 mosquée dont l'audit
l'immigration c'est formidable tout va
très bien et c
c'est le premier de sujets de
préoccupation des sciences risque est
d'accord il ya eu quelques attentats il
ya une délinquance endémique
il ya eu des centaines de morts des
milliers de blessés dans les attentats
c'est pas ma force et quoi y voit pas le
rapport
immigration
allez on l'a toujours du tout le monde
est toujours tout à fait d'accord pour
accueillir être tolérant et c'est
effectivement on a les levine un rôle à
on est les méchants fachos on est
raciste ou ce que vous voulez sauf que
abandonné hunter c'est vrai taisez vous
m'enlevez de la rance
on a demandé l'avis offert pour imposer
tout ça à quel moment on a fait un
référendum sur l'immigration pour leur
dire voilà on va accueillir 16 millions
d'immigrés qui partage avec vous ni la
lancée du lion michèle tribalat 2011
soulager les chiens n 10 s'est passé
parce que des chiffres et où nous
arrêter à votre liste
ben oui c'est très important jamais
demandé aux français s'ils étaient
d'accord ou pas pour vivre ensemble on
dit sélection ensemble mérité est ce
qu'on aura demander l'avis aux français
à aucun moment il ya des élections les
élections avec les élections mais vous
savez c'est toujours moi y est bien que
forcément mais c'est calaisis va bien
sûr au monde
moi ce que je voudrais avoir quand même
ce que je voudrais savoir c'est pourquoi
les européens devraient être les seuls
en permanence à devoir accueillir toute
la misère
il ya une autre chose et cette vision
c'est moi parler mais ça va parler
vincent là vous dites là vous dit une
bêtise il n'ya pas qu'il ait pas que
l'immigration qu'on aura mais on avait
écouté mes séries il ya une frontière
entre la syrie et l'arabie saoudite
pourquoi l'arabie saoudite qui est la
mairie ce sujet sont dans les pays où
c'est ce qu'il vous réponde on veut pas
de dénis grand chez nous porsche est
économiste professeur et s'étaler ibra
n'est pas en même temps comment de
clavecin pouvoir a compris que les
chiffres ne n'avais pas la même valeur
qui viennent de l'isard y ait de l'eau
cd ou d'un groupuscule qui est un think
tank que personne ne connaît c'est
important qu'il ya des chiffres qui sont
des chiffres l'hymne officiel et qui ont
une valeur plus que le chiffre de je
sais je sais pas qui du point qui après
je ne sais pas quelles études et qui
sert je ne sais pas quel intérêt
c'est important de le rappeler ça donc
moi c'est des chiffres 2007 là ce qu'on
entend c'est quoi c'te morceau modo
l'envahissement le grand remplacement et
le manque d'intégration et le fait que
grosso modo notre culture va être bouffé
par d'autres cultures
les flux migratoires ils sont clairs
nets c'est l'onu qui les détermine ok on
peut parler statistiquement un chiffre à
peu près valable c'est 0 2 0 3 % de flux
migratoires par an en france donc les
envahisseurs 0 2 3% par an ça représente
combien de personnes 250
ça fait deux le grison
rien n'est ce pas rentrer je finis le
grand remplacement vous l'avez montré
dans votre reportage la population
immigrée ses 9 % de la population
française le grand remplacement n'a pris
un point cinq ans 30 ans catane - 5
vous voyez alors les nous des gens âgés
immigrés attendez je continue oui au
président hongrois auriol la région il
ya le plus d'immigrés c'est l'île de
france c'est aussi la région le score du
fn est un des plus bas
c'est ça la réalité ça me fait du non
bis - semble que les gens qui vivent
preuve d'immigrés sont les plus racistes
c'est faux les villes du 93 c'est là où
il ya le plus d'immigrés bah c'est pas
elle qui va c'est là où il faut le voilà
qu'on est dans un communiqué le gagner
voilà donc à quoi donc arrêtons arrêtons
le maître caezar et on sait quoi c'est
sophie blavet dans votre tête qu'ils
sont maintenant mais bien sûr pensé mais
dans les eaux du ruisseau c'est donc ce
prêt vous ne rêvez pas nous ça peut être
intégré à ce moment là quand même bon
chez moi et la plupart sur la tête
d'europe 1 eric naulleau faut rappeler
deux fait légale l'immense majorité la
quasi-totalité des réfugiés et des
migrants le sont dans des pays arabes
mais payer la pauvre oui oui dans
l'arabie saoudite ni le coffre
[Musique]
il est intéressant de savoir lire les
récits rien le sont principalement en
syrie même au liban et dans d'autres
pays à l'union et urbain 15% sont dans
des pays arabes en aromatique et
deuxièmement le plus brûlant terrorisée
moi c'est la fille devient le plus grand
contingent de syriens après le libre et
c'est pas un pays arabe
d'accord cyril pas la france est un pays
après les deux l'atrazine vous c'est du
pipeau c'est une théorie complotiste
complotistes mais oui que je rappelle y
aurait un tableau alors ça doit être
éliminé la famille rothschild les
rothschild réal et à gare du nord alors
garé aller à gonesse enfin franchement
écoute organise sa serais bien leurs
gagnants place au nom des populations
locales par les populations immigrées ce
que vous soutenez c'est une théorie du
complot mais non on rigole ça fait déjà
pression mais je voulais des cours peut
discuter du reste rationnellement mais
ça c'est pipeau alors une mosquée a été
mutilée par seif al-islam sa remplaçants
et titulaires j'aimerais bien savoir b
attendait beaucoup de son coup d'essai
[Applaudissements]
vous dira sans vote concernant ses
attaches et brisé d'aidé d'abord les
français
et si les contenus de s'occuper
d'intégration fait si les musulmans
attendait parce que les rapports sur
l'intégration tout ça c'est bien joli
mais c'est ça le vrai dans la rue monge
et demi les grosses motos par des
migrants étaient prêts à la lutte et
factuelle arrivée dans l'hérault
évidemment on les trouvait pas dans les
statistiques mais ça c'est la réalité de
la rue moi je suis un peu déçu non pas
entendus les uns côté il ya les
batailles les idéologies politiques qui
me fatigue
la réalité elle est proche de karim
zéribi qu'est ce qu'on voit par exemple
les restaurateurs ils vont prendre la
main des étrangers leur emmené pour
avoir des papiers pour pouvoir
travailler dans leur entreprise
voilà la réalité est différente manier
on en a parlé dans tous les jt toutes
les infos mais ce bal à la réalité pour
la réalité c'est qu'on a dans les
travaux publics c'est pareil dans les
dents les mettre dans le métier serbie
géré par m
les médecins pareils les infirmières
pareil autre point les lions bas
n'oublions pas là mais le lenovo asus si
on l'oublié pas la colonisation à nous
accepter
là on a des échelles larqué en
commentateur et c'est fini après l'été
on a été on a été les chercher
aujourd'hui on n'en veut plus on les
jette on les vomis on fait quoi
c'est quoi cette france où on se dit oui
à la haine de l'autre justement dit on
va on a été les chercher on les vomis en
part au dernier point on va en algérie
on va passer aux matières premières
on va s'installer on va installer nos
entreprises là bas on va vendre nos
airbus dans des dandys vin parce que je
me reconcentre je peux entendre le mec
là
on est content d'aller bouffer une
prière montre nos airbus et cetera des
pays arabes par contre on veut pas
l'arabe on veut l'amérique et on veut
pas alors le regard on veut enlever l'on
veut on veut le couscous et on veut pas
le marocain mais justement je suis
désolé mais je me tourne vers dieu
[Applaudissements]